you'll notice of course the close
similarity to Leninist ideology to
Bolshevism which also assumes that the
radical intellectuals are the
specialized class the Vanguard may have
got to lead the stupid and ignorant
masses to a better society in fact the
two conceptions are very much alike I
think that's probably one of the reasons
why there's been historically such an
easy transition from one to another the
move from being Leninist enthusiast to a
you know a passionate supporter of state
capitalism and you know working for
American aims that takes place overnight
it's been going on for years it's called
the God that failed transition and it
happens very simply I mean in the early
stages it had some authenticity to it
when people like Ignacio Salona and
others were making this transition but
in recent years it's become just a farce
I mean technique of opportunism and the
transition is very easy I think because
there isn't much of a difference in
ideological change it's just a matter of
where you think power lies if you think
there's going to be a popular revolution
and you can ride that revolution to
state power and then wield the whip over
the masses you're a Leninist enthusiast
if you see that that's not going to
happen and power lies in the state
capitalist institutions which you have
to serve as a manager an ideological
manager you do that but it's basically a
very similar position and in fact in the
last century or so since there's been a
more or less identifiable secular
Intelligencia I think you find typically
that they fall into one or the other of
these two categories they associate
themselves with one or the other system
of power and hierarchy and subordination
in fact what I just said is almost a
tautology it's only if you submit to
those systems that you're counted as a
respectable intellectual for obvious
reasons well coming up to more modern
times in the post Second World War
period character find again deep concern
over the need to control and deceive the
public to control
PublicMind presidential historian Thomas
Bailey wrote in 1948 at the time when we
were sort of setting off on a new war
that cold war he wrote because the
masses are notoriously short-sighted and
generally cannot see danger until it's
at their throats our statesmen are
forced to deceive them into an awareness
of their own long-run interests
deception of the people may in fact
become increasingly necessary unless
we're willing to give our leaders in
Washington a freer hand and in 1981 as
the United States was launching a new
crusade for freedom Samuel Huntington
the professor of government at Harvard
said in a private but published
discussion an interchange you may have
to sell intervention or other military
action in such a way as to create the
misimpression but it is the Soviet Union
that you're fighting that's what the
United States has been doing ever since
the Truman Doctrine which is quite
accurate and gives a certain insight
into the nature of the Cold War in
particular into the nature of the war
against Nicaragua which is what he
specifically had in mind
well these concerns over controlling the
public mind tend to rise to the surface
particularly after periods of wars and
turmoil like the 17th century revolution
a civil war or like the First World War
when Woodrow Wilson launched the major
Red Scare which is the major example in
modern American history of all of
American history of state repression
that was really large-scale and
effective in destroying unions and
destroying independent politics and
eliminating independent thought and so
on and the same thing happened after
World War two with the phenomenon that's
mislabeled McCarthyism it's mislabeled
because it was actually initiated by the
Liberal Democrats in the late 1940s
McCarthy just came along at the tail end
of it and vulgarized it a little the
reason for this is an
is that periods of wars and turmoil have
a tendency to arouse people from apathy
and to make them think and to make them
organize often so that's why you get
things like the Red Scare and
McCarthyism right after periods of war
and turmoil and the same thing happened
after the Vietnam War which had the same
effect after the Vietnam War elites were
concerned about what they called a
crisis of democracy in fact one of the
most interesting books on this topic or
one of the most interesting books on
most of the insightful books I think on
modern on the modern democratic system
is called the crisis of democracy it's a
study the only book-length study
published by the trilateral commission
so important group put together by David
Rockefeller in 1973 and it represents
the more or less liberal
internationalists from the three major
centers of modern capitalism the United
States Western Europe and Japan and its
trilateral and remember this is the
Liberals this is the group out of which
Jimmy Carter and most of his
administration came the quite what's the
crisis of democracy that they're
concerned with in all of the democratic
societies well the crisis is that during
the 1960's large groups of people who
are normally passive and apathetic began
to try to enter the political arena to
press their demands and that's a crisis
which has to be overcome so the naive
might call that democracy but that's
because they don't understand the
sophisticated understand that that's a
crisis of democracy the American
spokesmen again Samuel Huntington wrote
in his report that Harry Truman had been
able to govern the country with the
cooperation of a relatively small number
of Wall Street lawyers and bankers in
those days there was no crisis of
democracy things were working just right
but in the 1960s he got all this turmoil
I mean young people and women and you
know labor and all kinds of weird people
who were supposed to be sitting quietly
and the corners began to get involved
and caused this crisis I mean the same
crisis that arose in the 17th century
and there repeatedly arrived
is when people begin to try to take
advantage of the formal opportunities
that exist among the terrible things
that were happening during the 60s
causing this crisis they said was that
you had this group of people who they
called value-oriented intellectuals
people who are concerned with things
like truth and justice and all that sort
of nonsense and they're opposed to the
good guys that technocratic and policy
oriented intellectuals they called them
the commissar that ones who just do the
job you know which had these
value-oriented intellectuals they were
doing all sorts of horrible things like
under my D legitimizing the institutions
that are responsible for the
indoctrination of the young like schools
and universities remember this is an
internal discussion so they kind of let
their hair down there are general
proposal at the end of all of this these
lengthy and thoughtful discussions was
that what we need is more moderation and
democracy to mitigate the excess of
democracy and overcome the crisis in
plain terms what that means is that the
public has to be reduced to their proper
state of apathy and obedience and driven
from the public arena if democracy is to
survive and the appropriate sense with
the specialized class you know the cool
observers are smart guys the
technocratic and policy you're an
intellectuals doing our job in the
interests of the people who have real
power
that's the liberal side I won't go into
what the reactionary side says about the
matter well to summarize there is a
standard view of democracy and it's the
view of Justice Powell the public should
assert or the review that he expressed
at least the the view that the public
ought to assert meaningful control over
the political process and there's a
contrary view the contrary view is the
public's a dangerous enemy and it has to
be controlled for its own good of course
the way you control children like you
don't let a three-year-old run across
the street the first view is the
rhetorical view the second view is the
view that's actually held
and you can see that it's actually held
when a crisis of democracy erupts and
the unwashed masses begin to try to
enter into the political arena and have
to be somehow repressed either by force
as in the Red Scare or by other means in
order to overcome the crisis of
democracy well with regard to the media
play a big role in this and with regard
to the media too there is a standard
view the standard view for example is
expressed again by justice Powell and
the same discussion when he claims that
it's the crucial role of the media to
affect the societal purpose of the First
Amendment that is to allow the public to
assert control of the political process
standard view was also expressed by
Judge Gurfein in an important decision
the Pentagon Papers decision when he
permitted the New York Times to publish
the Pentagon Papers and he said we have
a cantankerous press an obstinate press
a ubiquitous press and it must be
suffered by those in authority in order
to preserve the even greater values of
freedom of expression and the right of
the people to know that's one view
that's the standard view and given that
view we then have a debate the debate is
over whether the quit over whether the
media have gone too far in their
defiance of authority and their
adversarial stance the right wing claims
they've gone too far they're overcome by
a liberal bias we've got to do something
about it
the Liberals as in the Trilateral
Commission or in fact agree they in the
same study they say that the media
threatened government authority by their
adversarial stance and they've got to be
curved
if they can't curb themselves the
government is going to move in to curve
curb them the executive director of
Freedom House Leonard Sussman asked
whether free institutions must be a must
free institutions be overthrown by the
very freedom they sustain rhetorical
question meaning we got to do something
about this excess freedom that the press
is using to attack the government he was
writing about the Freedom House study of
the coverage that
that offensive which became a sort of a
classic allegedly showing that the press
lost the war in Vietnam by unfair
criticism of the government during the
Tet Offensive it's an interesting if
there's no time to talk about it
I may try to get back to it if not maybe
get through the discussion a very
interesting study was total fraud
falsified the data you know whole thing
was faked
when you actually correct the errors it
turns out that the press that the real
charge of Freedom House was that the
press although completely supportive of
the government policy and working
completely within the framework of
government propaganda nevertheless was
too pessimistic they said they didn't
tell you by what standards it was too
pessimistic the obvious standard is to
compare it with say internal US
intelligence assessments which we have
thanks to the Pentagon Papers and it
turns out the press was more optimistic
than US intelligence because they were
believing the public statements and they
know about the private statements so
Freedom House's complaint reduces to the
fact that the press though those totally
supportive of the propaganda didn't do
it in an upbeat enough fashion I
wouldn't have surprised George Orwell
that that should be the criticism of the
press produced by an organization called
Freedom House but that's become the
that's become the standard since
everyone refers to that as the study
that proves that the press was too
adversarial well that's the debate then
then the defenders of the press say no
we're not to adversary or maybe we are
too adversarial but you gotta tolerate
us even though we're cantankerous and so
on that's essentially the issue